will you please join me in prayer
Oh God may the words of my mouth and the
meditations of each of our hearts be
acceptable in your sight O God you are a
rock and our Redeemer amen so who has
authority in your life what sources do
you consult for the truth when you have
a question or a problem the answers you
give today are definitely different than
the answers we would have heard 50 or
100 years ago
I think we're far less trusting of
Authority these days and for good reason
the problem also today is that we have
so many voices telling us what to
believe that we just may be more
confused than ever if there is a
question on your mind where do you go
for answers my very unscientific made-up
study says that 48% of you would go to
Google really 25% of you might ask a
friend maybe 10% of you would ask a
family member maybe 17% of you would
consult some authoritative texts on the
question sifting through those options
for yourself of course it depends what
the dilemma is what the question is you
have in mind but think about the sources
of authoritative information in your
life the number of possible sources is
so huge we are more confused than ever
and if the question is a matter of faith
some deep theological question where do
you go
do you pray about it do you read
theologians do you flip through your
Bible do you google it what do we do
when this staggering number of sources
leaves us more confused than ever before
on the one hand we are understandably
skeptical of Authority it's hard to know
who we can trust but even more we want
to find the answers ourselves on the
other hand I think we do share a deep
deep longing for a guide we can trust
through this maze of life if you haven't
noticed the Gospel of Mark is off to an
incredibly fast start it begins with a
few memorable lines about John the
Baptist proclaiming the coming of Christ
only three verses on the baptism of
Jesus two verses covering Jesus forty
days of fasting and temptation in the
wilderness
a few quick verses of Jesus calling the
disciples follow me okay no time for
questions marks in a hurry so our gospel
passage today is only a few paragraphs
into mark and here mark spends more time
on Jesus teaching in the synagogue and
an exorcism than he has on most anything
else so far in his gospel jesus walks
into the gospel into the synagogue and
begins teaching he taught as one having
authority
mark says most who spoke in the
synagogue had authority but this Jesus
was different it seems people really
were listening to his teaching astounded
wondering who he was one in particular
knew who Jesus was a man with an unclean
spirit who began yelling at Jesus what
have you to do with us Jesus of Nazareth
have you come here to destroy us I know
who you are the Holy One of God we may
be tempted to label this person's
condition slap on a diagnosis of mental
illness or call security to have him
contained and escorted out chaos is
uncomfortable and chaos around us in
places of worship or anywhere else where
we're supposed to just sit and be quiet
is extra uncomfortable in dismissing
this man we forget that our own spirits
may not be as perfectly clean as we
think as everyone around Jesus is
listening quietly and puzzling over who
he might be this one who we may label as
troubled is actually the one who knows
who Jesus is the
with the unclean spirit calls Jesus the
Holy One of God
and faced with a wild man yelling at him
Jesus does not run away from this chaos
nor does Jesus leave this man burdened
by that unclean spirit he calls out that
spirit and sets him free some call this
an exorcism some call this a miracle
mark calls this Jesus teaching Jesus
teaches not only through his words to
the crowd in the synagogue that day but
through his stunning actions he steps
toward the chaos of life instead of
turning away from it
Jesus listens to every voice especially
those that the rest of us would rather
ignore and finally Jesus calls out
whatever is possessing us you probably
don't think you're possessed but really
you've never suffered from deep fear or
greed or workaholism surely not here
consumerism addiction I could go on
these and other unclean spirits are very
much a part of our lives and if you
think this talk of unclean spirits
sounds really out there
I assure you that many among us struggle
and if you find that this is hitting
close to home
I assure you that many around you are
also struggling in the Lord's Prayer we
all pray that God will deliver us from
evil even if we don't quite understand
what this means the thing is our world
is in need of healing we are in need of
healing though it is painful to admit
this and we are also in need of one with
authority whom we can turn to for new
life not a political leader not a
presidential candidate not even a
pastoral leader but the Holy One of God
Jesus Christ only Christ can call out of
us what is chaos
and bring us lasting peace in the poetic
words of Jan Richardson to all that is
chaotic and you let there come silence
let there be a calming of the clamoring
a stilling of the voices that have laid
their claim on you that have made their
home in you that go with you even to the
holy places but will not let you rest
will not let you hear your life with
wholeness or feel the grace that
fashioned you let what distracts you
cease let what divides you cease let
there come an end to what diminishes and
demeans and let depart all that keeps
you in its cage let there be an opening
in the quiet that lies beneath the chaos
where you find the peace you did not
think possible and see what shimmers
within the storm if we dare to admit
that we are in need of this this kind of
peace we may be considered weak by our
peers and questioned by our loved ones
if we dare to admit that we cannot find
our way completely on our own which is
why I think most of us are here this
morning then it is possible that Christ
is already transforming your life slowly
calling out of you those things which
hold you captive slowly melting our
hearts of stone and giving us hearts of
flesh that will break open to care for
others if we dare to recognize the one
with the unclean spirit as ourselves
then we too may just be able to say that
Jesus is in fact the Holy One of God
that Christ can in fact make us new
crazy absolutely true
I guess I'm banking my life on it the
uncertainties of our days are many many
and when we've searched for answers long
enough without finding clarity or peace
Jesus meets us right there in the chaos
and the confusion Christ knows what is
consuming our lives and has the power to
transform us as we question authority
and wonder what to believe and grasp for
anything that is certain in this world
Jesus reminds us that truth can be found
even in the chaos the chaos of an infant
born in a barn far far from home the
chaos struggle with whatever is
consuming our lives the chaos of the
cross the chaos of those who discover
the empty tomb on Easter morning the
chaos of Christ rearranging our
carefully made plans and loosening our
grip on our will if you try to live with
Christ as the main authority figure in
your life
I promise you it will be uncomfortable
there will be chaos there will be doubt
and more questions it might be funny
sometimes but it will not always be fun
and I promise that sometimes God will
pry you from a place where you are
comfortable and happy and send you on
your way to someplace else just when you
think who we made it okay let's put down
some roots here for a while longer God
will speak to you as God did long ago we
hear in Deuteronomy
you have stayed long enough at this
mountain continue on your journey it
breaks in my heart to say goodbye to you
and this is because it has been a deep
privilege to serve you for
five-and-a-half years
Ian promised this would be a three
hankie service but I am excited what's
ahead for Jeff and me and I'm excited
what's ahead for this church God is
sending us off this holy mountain to
another place God is sending you to
another place too and that's not because
I'm leaving it's not it's because God is
always always calling us forward and
onward and home